[音楽]
b
私はこういうプレゼンテーション英語でもさことないのに何故か今日
深いこと世界観について日本語で話すことにした
頑張る
私は典型的なアメリカの田舎ものです
大学まで本当の魚と米は1回も食べたことがなかった
初めて飛行機に乗ったのは大学を卒業したあとです
だから23歳のとき日本に来て全然日本のことを知らんかったです
しかも日本語を勉強する気は全くなかった
彼氏は日本語を勉強せんといけんやって言ったんだけど私や日本に住むことだけでなん
とかなるさって言った
日本に来て4か月経った頃に本性先から自分のマンションに引っ越すことになった
日本に住んでるから日本人黒洗剤を買って引っ越しの挨拶しに行こうかなと思った
あの取られにトントンしたら中から声が聞こえてきた
誰ですかはしまった
一生懸命その大事なプレーずつまらないものですがを練習したけどこういう質問に答え
られんかったな
しばらく考えた後
外人ですって答え位
笑いながら出てきてくれて洗剤を足した後
彼氏の良いに戻ってすぐ英語の姉ブルー単語を調べたん
多分その日初めてやっぱり日本語勉強せんといけんなと思った
そのときの自分はこんな感じだったん
日本の府営もかけてたけど何も見えての方です
けどその日から一生懸命日本語を勉強し始めた
2005年に日本語能力試験の1基を取った
ヨッシュ言葉のレンズが入ったぞ
少し日本のことが見えてきた
同時に日本の文化に馴染もうとした子供3人とも日本の産婦人けどに出し日本の額に
行かせた
そして日本について本も書いた
よし日本について本書いたから専門家になった場合
文化なおレンズも入れましょう
フォト本と文具のレンズはしっかり入ってるから
日本のすべてが見えていると思ったけど実は1年半くらい前にあんまり見えてないこと
に気づいた
[音楽]
その時進入の真紀子さんに出会った
彼女と私の違いはマジハンパないん
負け子は8仏教神事でいる京都人
私はキリスト教信じているアメリカの田舎もの
共通点が全くないけどなんとかそれを乗り越えてすごく高い友達なった
なのによく文化のことでぶつかった
育児とか食事
どうして私は日本の文化を知るはずがこんなに負けことぶつかるとってすごく不思議に
思った
でもある日その答えが来た
まあ結構は一生懸命キリスト教勉強し始めた
なぜかというと私が大好きだから私が大事にしていることを知りたくてたまらんかった
かです
一緒に教会に行ったりと召喚から方の借りたり必死に勉強した
すごくうれしかったけどある木人生を変えられるようなことに気づいた
私は同じような心がなかったです
私は負け子が大事にしていること全然興味がなかった
深く反省して結審した
それから一緒に神社と寺に行ったりあの仲間で日本の歴史について話したりした
けど私の人生に一番大きいにパッドがあったのは一緒に料理をするようになるという
ことです
私はどんだけ料理が嫌いだったって誰もがしている
もう有名だから昔からの友達に私料理習ってるぞって言ったらみんな本当に気絶しそう
になると
正直私はあまり興味がなかったん
負け子は料理が大好きだったから一緒にやりたかっただけです
でも少しずつできるようになって
去年初めて味噌汁を作れるようになっ
受けるやろ
年間日本に住んでるけど去年まりは味噌汁は作れなかった
そのインスタントのやつはずっと波寄った
で料理をしながら日本の食文化について深く話してた
その会を通してすごく大事なこと気づいた
今まで日本の文化の表面しか見えてなかったです
その深いところ
理解しづらいところとか納得いかないところ
それ全然理解しようとしなかったですでもねそれは一番大事なところ
それは日本の心
それは日本の世界観です
で世界観って一体何やろう
あまり日常生活に出てくるような単語じゃなかろ
たぶんこの部屋に人生に一回も世界観に行ったことない人がいるかもしれない
じゃあ皆さんにそう言いましょうか性能
はい
人生に一回打ったことがある
[音楽]
簡単に言うと世界観とは人間がどう有名でこの世界を見るかということです
人間の行動と価値観そして国の文化は全部世界観から来ている
でももうすかしたら文化と世界観の違いがあまりわからないと思ってる人がいるかも
しれないからもっと説明します
いいに例えると
文庫はその家の見える部分
やねえ壁
家具とか
でもそのしたりは見えない土台がありますそれは世界観
この世界観の土台がないと家の家を建てることができません
もう一つの例を挙げましょう
日本人は赤ちゃんと一緒に寝る習慣がある
それは文化でもなぜ赤ちゃんと一緒に寝ると
なんでアメリカ人は一緒に寝ないとそれは世界観
その世界観のなぜか分からないと文化の何を理解することができません
私気づいたのは今までのメガネのかけ方が間違い突破
ここは言葉と文化じゃなくてここは
ここに言葉も文化も入っている
で左目に入れなきゃいけない
でこのレンズは世界観
世界観のレンズを右に入れなきゃいけない
士会館のレンズが入ってないとすべて見えることができません
じゃあ食べ物の話に戻りましょう去年の5月に友達と一緒に運動会に行ったん
右側で私はおにぎり3分の1ぐらいのポスター
まあ食べた方がいて分かったけどでもまあイランからまあいいやと思ったけど友達は
相当嫌な顔してた
家に戻った後その濃厚されておにぎりについて
1時間のフェイスブックのやり取りしてたよ1時間
でこういうこと言われた
ワンちゃん
the 焼かないの
食べをの大事にしないの
すごい不思議に思ったなんでこれを握りについて来い重い話になってるといいがわから
ない
思ったけどね意味がわからなかったのは日本の食文化の世界観が理解できなかったから
です
じゃあいただきます中丹後を考えましょう
食べる前にいただきますいうのは日本の文化それ私は買ってたけど
なぜいただきますいうの
それは日本の世界観でそれずっとわからんかったから
いただきまーすお列いい食べましょうっていうふうに訳した
でも考えていただきまーそれツイーツじゃなかろ
いただきます y の子をいただきます命を捧げてくれた動物と植物にありがとう地
気持ちを表す表現です
でもそれだけじゃなくて食べ物を作った人を取った人運んで人そして勝利してくれた人
に感謝の気持ちを表す
つまり食べ物のプロセスの最小の段階から自分の食卓に乗るまでみんなの協力で3など
で6で食べる権利があるぞ
大事にしなきゃいけないよおにぎりのコストの亀様っていうことは全部いただきます
意味に入ってる
えっ
それは私ずっとわからんかった
から二章的に言うと食べ物を大事にする
人間じゃなかった定期頭に買って定期頭に作って適当につけたけど変わった
[音楽]
私は日本人との世界観が同じじゃない
けど食べ物を大事にするのはどんな世界観でもどんな考えでもいいことだと思います
これ思うようになったら食べ物との関係が変わった
今まで好き嫌いが半端なかったあんちゃんは何でも食べるようになった
今まで魚が大嫌いだった私は
さばけるようになったばいい
で今まで味噌汁さえ少なかった私は去年
おせち料理作れたスゴカロ
でも一番素晴らしいことは
25年間戦ってきた摂食障害を克服した
なぜこの1年間だけでこんなに成長ができたと
に本の世界からの理解しようとする心が生まれたからです
皆さんに言いたい子痛いことがある
もう少したら外国語を勉強しているかもしれない
もう少したら海外に行く機会があるかもしれないん
言葉と文化を理解することだけで満足しないでください
そういう深いところ世界観を理解しようとしたら人生は豊かになります
けどね
日本から出なくてもいいんですよ
自分の周りに世界観と考え方が違う人に囲まれている
上司友達納涼お母さん
奥さん子供
働いている人は自分の上司の考え方を理解しようとしてますか
旦那さんは
奥さんが大事にしていることが分かりますか
それか考え方が違いすぎるから理解せずに諦めて地 now んですか
私はこのプレゼンテーションの準備している間にすごく職員がことに気付いた
って
私は日本の世界観を一生懸命理解しようとしたけど自分の犯行中の娘を理解しようと
全然しなかったです
彼女が大事にしていることに全然興味がなかった
改めて反省して結審した
ん
これからだこれから彼女が大事にしていること
を折り返し様とするそしてもっと時間過ごしあげたり話を聞いてあげたりする
あなたの周りに同じような人がいるかどうか考えてみてください
人間は成長するためにこういう反省するような心がすごく大事です
私の好きな言葉はエリックバウンサーの名言
他人と過去を変えられないけど自分と将来を変えられる
この言葉を考えながら成長を求めてお互いを理解しようとする人間になりましょう
ありがとうございます
[拍手]